we tend to learn self-pity when we're
young maybe was a sunny Sunday afternoon
you were nine years old your parents
wouldn't let you have any ice cream if
you didn't do your maths homework
it was achingly unfair every other child
in the world was playing football or
watching TV no one else had such a mean
mother it was just awful we're all in
theory dead against self-pity
it seems deeply unattractive because it
reveals egoism in its most basic form
the failure to put our own suffering
into proper perspective against the
larger backdrop of human history we
lament are tiny disasters and look
coldly on the grand tragedies of the
world a problem with one's fringe or a
wrongly cooked steak dominates the mind
while we ignore working conditions in
China and the Gini coefficient of Brazil
no one likes to own up to self-pity and
yet if we're honest it's something we
feel quite often and in fact it's often
rather a sweet and indeed important
emotion the fact is we do deserve a
great deal more pity than other people
are ever very likely to bestow upon us
life is in truth horrendously hard in
many ways even if one does have a
top-notch data plan and an elegantly
designed fridge our talents are never
fairly recognized our best years will
necessarily drift away we won't find all
the hope we won't find all the love we
need we deserve pity and there isn't
anyone else around to give it to us so
we have to supply a fair dose of it to
ourselves
the operative cause might from a lofty
perspective seem ridiculous for me I'll
never drive a Ferrari it's so sad I
thought we were going to a Japanese
restaurant and they've booked a pub but
these are just the convenient
opportunities for immersing ourselves in
a much bigger issue the fundamental
sorrows of existence for which we do
genuinely deserve the most tender
compassion imagine what things would be
like if we couldn't pity ourselves we
would be that far worse category of
mental discomfort depressed the
depressed person is someone who has lost
the art of self-pity who has become too
rigorous with themselves if you think of
a parent comforting a child they
and spend hours on very minor things a
lost toy new news broken eye the
children's party to which one wasn't
invited
they're not being ridiculous they're in
effect teaching the child how to look
after themselves and giving space to the
important idea that small upsets can
have very large internal consequences
gradually we learn to mimic this
parental attitude and come to be able to
feel sorry for ourselves when no one
else will it's not necessarily entirely
rational but it's a coping mechanism a
first protective shell which we develop
in order to be able to manage some of
the immense disappointments and
frustrations that life throws at us
the defensive posture of self-pity is
far from contemptible it's touching and
important many religions have given
expression to this attitude by inventing
deities who look with inexpressible pity
upon human beings in Catholicism for
instance the Virgin Mary is often
presented as weeping out of tenderness
for the miseries of the normal human
life such kindly divine beings are
really just projections of our own need
to be pitied self-pity is compassion
that we extend to ourselves a more
mature aspect of the self turns to the
weak and lost parts of the psyche and
comforts them strokes them tells them it
understands and that they are indeed
lovely but misunderstood it allows them
to be for a while a bit babyish since
that is actually what we all are in
large part it provides the undemanding
confirming love that every baby but far
more importantly every adult needs to
get through the anguish of existence
you